I bet if you asked everybody in Isis why  they joined over 40 would say traffic  because traffic can turn a reasonable  rational human being to a murderous  monster  you ever been at a four-way stop and  it's not your turn to go but it's a  person in front of you it's their turn  to go but they're not going they're  doing this go go go go go go go go go go  no you oh good good good good and you're  behind him like  you have to go or nobody's ever gonna go  there are rules in places for this  situation  you're not going to get into heaven for  letting somebody go first in a four-way  stop because I'm gonna stab someone and  that shit's going on your tab she says  go go go go go go go it's gonna leave  [Applause]  listen you guys you cannot be nice with  someone else's time that is not how  kindness works if you want to be nice  join the big brother or the big sister  program and bring a kid to the movie but  on your way to the theater [ __ ] go